Wants to...
discuss anything,
please type it out on the chat and please
put up your hand. Good morning, everybody.
Please put down the subject which you
want to discuss in the chat and please
put up your hand if there's any
clarification, any query.
Today is the last day for asking for
extension of assignment one with reason.
And you have to request it in the
beginning of the class.
that you felt sick or you had internet
problem or technology issues in the last
day is never accepted as an explanation.
If you're having problems today, yes,
we'll take it up.
Okay.
Accepted.
Yeah.
You want to understand about architecture
trade-off?
An answer method will dedicate a full
class to it, but when? Let me check up.
In CS7, we will be taking up the ATM, so..
.
You will have to either attend CS7 or...
Watch the recording.
So a time will be taken up in CS7.
On assignment wise,
is there specific PPT template for
submission? No, there's no PPT template,
but there's a template on.
The item to be covered in each slide.
There are no marks for PPT style design.
Okay, let's put it that way.
I guess you've seen the...
items to be covered in each on each slide.
Any clarification on that I can talk
about,
but you are free to use even a totally
non-stylish plain vanilla template will
do.
is the content that will count.
Okay.
How are you, Soni?
Who?
So since there's nothing else,
let's get started with today's session.
We'll be discussing structures and views.
Before taking up structures and views,
I will quickly...
Review.
something about architecturally
significant requirement. So first thing,
what is an ASR?
It's a requirement. As a requirement,
an ESR should be measurable.
It should have a profound impact on the
system software and the hardware
architecture.
So any requirement that's going to have a
profound impact
On the software and the hardware
architecture is called architecturally
significant, and...
It should address a requirement.
And when we say a requirement,
it is a quality requirement with a
specific scenario which should be
measurable.
We've been through this,
that everything we do,
we have to make sure it is measurable.
How do you come to know whether...
A requirement is architecturally
significant or not.
It should have high business value.
It should pose technical risks.
Key stakeholders should be interested in
it.
It should address a unique functionality
of the system.
It should address any non-standard demand.
And it should represent items which have
caused budget overruns in the past.
So you can understand this.
Basically.
It is a tiger that you need to.
PM, PA meeting, okay?
What are the drivers?
that influence the identification and
prioritization of ASRs.
So you go to identify them and place them
in an order of priority.
Business goals.
What are the business goals you need to?
Relate them to the business goals.
Whether you have anything to do with the
business goals or not? If not,
cannot be a priority. In fact,
may not even be.
Requirements.
We have to really go and find out, well,
do we need to do that?
It's got nothing to do with the business.
You want to have some dancers when you do
your login? What for you? Who wants it?
How much is the company willing to pay?
What's the return on investment?
Stakeholders concerns.
Does it address the concern of any
stakeholder?
Is any stakeholder interested?
Then does it address quality attributes?
Or is it got to do with some regulatory
compliances?
Any technology constraints? Well,
it's normally not possible.
We've got to launch a bomb from an
aircraft for which it has not been
designed. Okay, oh,
it's definitely architecturally
significant.
Bust.
If doing something is going to cost a lot,
it better be important.
So you need to think about it.
Time to market.
Time to market is a very important factor.
In fact...
Bug-ridden software is some have to be
released.
Just to be time to market,
because the first person takes it all.
So if you beat someone to the market,
it could be great.
How do simple functional requirements
differ from ESS? You know,
everything is a requirement,
so what's so special about ESS?
Normally simple requirements are
straightforward.
You've done it many times before.
It's something the programmer will be
able to handle.
You don't have to give any special
infrastructure or software or hardware to
handle that.
What is ours?
Address complex logic.
It could involve some critical aspects of
the system, like...
Detecting real-time.
or some very stringent NFR,
some quality attribute, but...
For some reason,
the stakeholders in the company is very,
very finicky about it.
It becomes architecturally significant.
What design decisions?
Which category of design decisions?
What an architectural architect inspect
to extract ESRs? Where do I look for ESRs?
In the documentation.
So.
You study the existing company,
find out how responsibilities are
allocated. Normally in any company,
anything that is significant has got
significant posts for it and with people
with a lot of authority.
To look at the coordination model,
how in the existing setup,
how things are coordinated?
What are the issues that the company
gives priority to coordinating?
How's the data storage currently being
handled?
Why it's handled the way it's handled?
What are the changes people are talking
about and why are they talking about it?
How resources have managed the company?
What are the suggestions that have come
up in the past for what reason?
How things are mapped at present and
what's the type of feedback that exists?
You know, sometimes feedback,
monitoring results,
they give you a lot of insight.
Because people are facing problems,
they bring it up.
And maybe at the time of design,
it's forgotten.
It's your job as an architect to rake it
up. That's okay.
These are things that existed in your
documents. People have talked about it.
Please give us your views.
What do you think about it?
You look at binding time decisions which
are documented.
What are the choice of technologies that
are available today?
The moment you look at these visa-vis the
system, sometimes you start realizing,
okay, this...
is a hint. You just look for hints.
Now,
you conduct quality attribute workshops,
QAWs.
Why do you conduct QAWs?
You basically construct QAWs,
these are workshops where important
stakeholders are present.
Because you want people to speak up.
The moment people speak up,
it helps you to understand the
requirements better.
You can consolidate the requirements,
prioritize the attributes.
come to a consensus.
Unless people speak up,
the truth will remain buried.
And the coastal rise.
when you go for implementation of the
system. So you've got to stoke the ghost.
to get silent people to speak up.
You got to get silent people committed.
to what the people have been speaking so
that they cannot come up later and say,
no, but I thought of it,
but I didn't speak it up. Damn said,
you didn't speak it up.
Is that?
Any standard format for defining business
goals, or...
Here are some illustrations.
When you talk about business goals.
When the person tells you,
this is our goal,
the next question you should be asking is,
what is the current status?
We want a market share of 65%.
What's your current market share? 10%.
Okay.
And you expect the software to do it.
Why do you believe the software will do
it?
What should I do in the software to help
your market share to go from 10% to 65%?
And if we cannot answer it up front,
we cannot say that, okay,
this is the attribute we require that
will drive the market share up.
We don't know what to work for because we
don't have some sort of a tool which will
just get a monitor and type in 65% and
the market share becomes 65%.
We have to do it.
through quality attributes.
through functionalities and features of
the software we develop.
So you've got to understand the business
goal, where you are,
where you intend to go,
and how do you intend to achieve it.
You tell us the quality attributes that
are required.
We'll achieve the quality attributes.
The responsibility of achieving business
goals through the quality attributes is
yours.
People who ask for quality attributes
have to commit to business goals.
Then we have got something called PAUL.
A degree.
So,
we said pedigree attribute elicitation
method.
So in elicitation,
we keep the E silent and L for pump.
P for pedigree, A for attribute,
L for elicitation, not E, and M is method.
Well, PAUL sounds good,
so the abbreviation.
Pedigree means tracing back to ancestors.
At PINDIPROLU,
attribute elicitation means connecting
every quality attribute to the business
call. Like I just told you that.
If you say that this is your business
goal,
what quality attribute do you think will
help you achieve it and connect it up?
Connection is the business's
responsibility.
Delivering the quality attribute is yours.
Getting stakeholders to commit that if
you will give me this quality attribute,
I'll achieve that.
is for you to help them do,
the management will hold them accountable
for it.
You are accountable for delivering
attributes, measurable. Remember,
always measurable.
You cannot talk about quality being in
the eyes of the beholder if you are an
architect.
No.
The utility tree,
you're supposed to draw it for your
assignment.
You must understand very thing clearly.
The root,
which you don't have to explicitly draw,
is the overall utility. That's the root,
but you don't have to draw it.
We understand the root.
Yes.
Overall utility.
The main branches are the quality
attributes, performance, availability.
modifiability, testability, security,
interoperability, scalability.
usability. These are quality attributes.
So these are the main.
sub-branches of overall utility.
And then the leaf nodes are the specific
scenarios.
And I'm sure now you've drawn a lot of
scenarios on your own.
And the moment we talk about a scenario,
As an architect, see,
there's another type of scenario which we
talk about when we write down the use
case story.
That's a scenario,
but the scenario for quality attributes
is...
Source of stimulus is stimulus working on
an artifact in an environment.
Giving a response which is measurable.
What do you want?
And when we talk about responses,
we talk about existing,
we talk about what is the least.
that will happen automatically,
what's the maximum possibly achievable,
and what do you want to target?
But that detail we'll get to later.
At present, you get to the utility tree.
Then how do you prioritize items within
the utility tree?
High, medium, low.
High, medium,
low from the point of view of the
importance to business.
The business wants and high, medium, low.
from the impact it has on the
architecture.
This quality attribute has a huge impact
on the architecture.
It requires a lot of architectural
thinking, maybe a lot of cost.
Complicated architectural decisions may
be involved.
So we say high on architecture.
So it's always a pair of two alphabets.
HML, HML. So it could be H, HM, HL.
You can have MHMMMMMLLHLMLL, so all these.
A combination, so to say.
You it can happen in all these
combinations.
So based on importance to business and
impact on architecture.
And how do you measure system site size?
KSLOCs we talked about,
killer software lines of code.
And how does it impact agility and
upfront architectural planning?
And we saw those models where we said
that small projects require minimal
upfront planning,
whereas large projects require more
upfront planning.
So these are basically the points,
if any of these points require
clarification,
I've reviewed it because your first
Assignment is heavily dependent on this.
It was important that we...
Brief you about it.
Remember the assignments?
For this course,
are we called Situational Learning
Assignments,
so please take up assignments with which
you can identify.
Because...
Most of you will carry forward assignment
one into assignment two,
though you are allowed to change.
If by the time you get into assignment
two, you want to change the subject,
most welcome.
You'll probably have to redo assignment
one privately to be able to get into
assignment two,
but then that's your lookout.
And then you'll be discussing it with
your peer, so don't take up a subject.
which makes you feel like a fish outside
water.
So, we'll start today's class.
We've done a quick review.
So any questions, any clarifications,
you're welcome.
Mics are unmuted. They are sort of mute,
unmute enabled.
And you can put up your hand and I put
something indicating the subject,
otherwise we carry on from here.
Okay.
I don't see any.
Comment on the meeting chat, so we move.
A structure is what is.
A view is what you comprehend or see or
you will make available for people to see.
A view is a representation of a structure.
A view is what your stakeholders will be
able to read.
A view is something your architect will
be able to write.
The structure.
is what is in the mind of the architect,
and at the end of the project,
it will be visible.
In the system that will be constructed.
So...
Thereby, structure is the reality,
view is the representation.
Do you represent?
You represent a lot of items, elements.
and the relationship between them.
Like,
you may have a whole lot of people and
they have relationships, husband, wife,
brother, sister.
parent, child,
whatever the relationship may be,
collaborators, business workers, boss,
subordinate, peer,
whatever the relationship elements and
the relation between them.
The actual human beings.
exist,
the actual human beings have relations.
But if you want to draw it in a chart,
your company draws it in an organization
chart. You can draw relationship diagrams,
whichever way.
You can write a beautiful story.
Shakespeare did it.
That was the way Shakespeare liked to
represent relationships.
You've got the very famous authors of
epics, like the Mahabalat and the Ramayan,
their views.
And the views survive long after the
structures,
and the views can come into existence
even before the structure exists.
There's a beauty about our view.
When you take a system and you break it
up into parts,
we call it a module structure.
A drawing depicting the structure.
is a model view. Now people say that,
why did you give us an example?
The moment somebody tells me to draw an
example.
What I do is...
I just draw a few boxes.
A draw box here, anything will do.
As long as...
You have depicted.
The system in units is a module structure.
In this course, we are not going to be.
excessively concerned about.
Nutrition.
If you really want to indicate,
you can write something here, element.
Straight line relation. OK, fine,
you defined it.
Now, nobody can fault you if you,
if you show it like this,
even for a simple thing like this,
even this is not required,
you can write your directional
association.
So...
This is a model structure.
Elements are modules.
They're units of implementation.
That means the moment you have developed
modules,
you can start distributing the work.
It's too cold.
If you're going to develop code,
it's a very complex system to take the
overall module.
You can divide it into,
at the very basic level, user interface,
middleware.
Database.
all the coding in the data,
all the procedures are here.
Middleware is here, which accesses,
maybe this could be lying in the data
link layer or the business layer.
So later on, we'll divide it into layers,
but at present, they're just modules.
And then user interface,
you were divided into various parts based
on the user model, admin, supervisors.
Customers.
So you may have different types of user
interfaces. You just break up and...
You can define functional
responsibilities for.
Take care of each of these.
Here,
we really don't bother about where you're
going to place it or whether this is
going to be the front end,
is going to this and this are going to be
in the same server, different services,
whether you go to a distributed database,
all those things we'll talk about later,
runtime.
And so what does the module structure
give you?
The functional responsibilities,
primarily these are the breakups of the
responsibilities.
It also gives you what software elements
a module is allowed to use this module.
will be allowed to use a particular type
of software.
What other software code is actually used?
Whether you'll be using certain
frameworks,
you might decide to use the Spring Boot
framework for doing the user interface.
You might use Windows Communication
Foundation.
With C-sharp code.
to do the middleware.
You might be using PLSQL.
On your Oracle database.
For doing the backend, so...
You can take these type of decisions once
you have broken up.
Then you can have generalization and
specialization relationship.
Typical example given is vehicle.
Car, truck.
So.
If you want to break up modules like this,
this is also possible.
So all generalized code will be under
vehicle,
specialized code will be under car and
truck.
If there are people who are not oriented
into...
particular brands of technology.
and you think it is necessary for you to
understand it even to get an overview
view, you're welcome to ask.
There's no embarrassment because
sometimes I get feedback from students
that, you know,
the stuff spoken about in the class went
totally above the head. Now,
that's not my intention.
I would rather let the people who can
understand complicated things do things
of their own.
But I would like to build a minimum
common standard.
So I'd rather people who are enthusiastic
attending the class, enthusiastically,
who are interested,
They should be able to come to class and..
.
get that time's worth.
And people who are already experts,
who know these subjects, well,
they can quickly watch the videos and
recording and go and study something more
meaningful to them.
They don't need to waste their time
understanding fundamentals. But remember,
you must go through the slides because
you are going to have a common
examination.
So,
you must be able to talk a language which
is more or less in conformity with the
way we are going about the course. So,
please.
Don't.
Come up.
Halfway through the course, I said,
everything just went OHT,
overhead transmission.
That is not the intention. I intend to...
explain things in as basic a way as
possible.
And I'm not interested in getting into
technical details,
but some technical details happen to come
so naturally that one can't control
oneself.
And people who are attending here with
one or two years experience probably
Did mechanical engineering or civil
engineering in the college,
but are in an IT job now.
Trying to come to terms with this
technology might have a little bit of
difficulty, but please,
we are here for you. OK, this comes into.
The large number of people have plussed
Abhinav. I hope that issue
Now has come to rest, Abhinav,
since everybody plus you,
you or an answer.
Are you OK with the reply given to you?
Yes, sir,
I was asking about is there any specific
template that we need to follow?
Yeah, I know that, I know that, and I,
I believe, yeah,
and I believe I've answered it,
so you should find that answer as
Yeah, yeah.
complete, right?
Yeah, but it's a good suggestion.
Maybe next time Brits may think of giving
us templates. In fact, you know,
this style of assignment,
I've been doing it for the last five
years. But this year,
they've selected a few courses where
they've said that your assignment has got
to be in situational learning.
And one of the courses identified was
software architecture, so,
and the overall structure.
The headings have been specified by the
institution.
So, is the same thing, old wine,
new bottle, but then that's it nowadays.
Systems are supposed to be.
in a proper way,
everybody's got to conform.
And you may be attending some other
courses also, which may have switched to,
but they've just switched a handful of
courses into situational learning.
But many faculty members,
out of their own experience,
would like to give you assignments and
involve you with your practical work.
And here's an opportunity on whichever
area you are knowledgeable in.
So please take up something in which you
have existing knowledge.
So you don't have two problems at a time.
One is obtaining knowledge and the other
is learning how to make an architectural
presentation. So at least
The subject should be known to you.
And you don't need to be aware again,
as I said in depth,
you don't need to know how to code the UI
or the business middleware or the backend
database or design the physical hardware
architecture or be aware of how the DLLs
are called.
or how the APIs are called. Nothing.
You don't need to be aware at that level.
But you should have at least used the
system.
as a user. You should have seen it.
You should be appreciative of what the
capability of the system is.
You should have some ideas on where you
would like the system to head,
some reasonable thinking you should be
able to put into it.
And if you have that capability,
you'll be able to contribute to your peer
group.
by giving them something which will be a
learning experience for them. See,
when you look at it from that point of
view,
you'll be able to do a much better job.
Don't look at it from the point of view
of something that is going to give you 5
marks. Your ticket,
those five marks are almost yours for the
taking. People who don't have time,
they just do a slipshot job.
they will not get the marks. So here,
the situation is not getting the marks.
The situation is being able to actually
utilize this assignment as an opportunity
for training.
So you are training yourself. In fact,
I'm very sorry that
I cannot take the advice of some very
senior.
teachers whom I got to encounter,
I admire the point of view.
So this person, a very senior person,
he tells me that the students cannot get
full marks.
Part of the responsibility is yours. Okay.
So I said,
does it mean that every student in my
class should be able to get full marks?
He says yes.
But I said, no,
Bits has got something called relative
grading. What do we do?
We're supposed to give a paper.
Which?
30%, anybody should be able to attempt.
30%,
a person with decent knowledge on the
subject should be able to attend.
And another 30% should be challenging.
Even if people can't attempt it,
it doesn't matter. So.
The average student is supposed to get a
C grade, so everybody...
who does a decent job,
or even a little better than decent,
gets a secret.
People who...
I'm the 30% category who could basically
touch the subject,
but they didn't know too much about it,
should be able to get a D.
And people who come up with a little bit
of smartness,
they should be able to get a B.
So I see grades only as B, C, and D.
I don't see A's and E's are not grades
for me.
These are for the outliners,
these are for the outliners at the other
end who are challenging the faculty that
do what you may,
I'm not going to get marks.
I'm not going to appear for the
assignment because it's not mandatory.
Assignments are not mandatory.
You don't have to do it.
You can still get a degree.
You will clear the course without doing
the assignment.
It's the easiest place to scope,
but it's the one which is not mandatory.
The quizzes are not mandatory.
Without appearing for a single quiz,
you can still clear the course, but...
God help you,
if you miss the midterm exam,
you'll have to repeat the course.
People either take the regular or the
makeup.
If you are using it for your convenience,
you're taking the makeup rather than
taking the regular,
you're taking a risk because you want to
distribute your load. Well,
it's like the software architecture,
high risk. You're taking a risk.
You have to take the call whether it is
worth the risk or not,
because there's no makeup for makeup. So
For some godforsaken reason,
if you miss the makeup, well,
you have to register and listen instead
to do it.
But then, I do know for a fact that...
A very large number of students do apply
for makeup because they want to plan to
have.
Two subjects in the regular and two in
the makeup. That's okay.
You take risks in life.
If it pays you off, it is worth it.
Your gambling, your health,
and the environment.
against your ability to pay for another
semester. It's okay.
But as far as quiz and assignment is
concerned, no compulsion.
You can afford to miss them.
But they are the ones which,
according to me,
have got the maximum learning content.
If you do your assignments properly.
Even if you don't do well in the exams,
you would have definitely learnt a lot,
particularly, you know,
after doing assignment two,
we are going to have that one week or so
discussion with your peer.
And I've seen that during that discussion,
if nothing else,
you at least read through everybody
else's assignment. So some 20,
30 assignments which you will get of your
peer.
you will read through them.
And when you read through them,
and then you will clarify some stuff
because you are supposed to ask some
intelligent questions.
If you don't ask some questions again.
you are not completing the requirement of
the discussion.
So in the process of asking some serious
questions,
you have to understand what that person
has written.
And if you can understand 30 different
Architectures from the practical lives of
30 people in your group,
I don't think you need to do much more
for the course. Okay,
so let's continue from there.
Yeah.
components and connectors.
Run 10 components.
And then...
You have the connectors.
Do we have glasses?
The same class may be instantiated more
than once.
Just for a tie version, I want to see.
All the quizzes are moving over here.
There's something I'd love to share with
you.
You might find this very interesting.
There are 205 people who have taken the
assignment.
160 have got between 14 and 15.
This is a histogram.
Indicating the appearance.
So.
People are getting in this category.
It's not going to harm them much.
Because if they continue scoring like
this, out of 15, they will get 7, 8 marks,
which is not bad. But...
You must understand that you are not
stupid, you know?
It's just that these people are using
some technology.
For getting the answers right,
the 165 here.
At 22 here.
So...
Then everybody's using technology.
You should not think that you're being
insincere in using it.
So the average is 14.1.
So I'm presenting this particularly when
some people feel that 5 minutes is too
little. In fact.
You're not alone.
Some of my faculty members feel that 5
minutes is too easy.
This is you could definitely give some
more time.
Ten minutes would have been a good idea.
So I normally present this to them.
I said, and they said, oh, no,
this is because people are using AI.
I said, OK, by giving 10 minutes,
will people stop using AI?
If you can give me some method.
Just stop here.
By doing 10 minutes, and I said,
"What's wrong with using AI?
As long as people come to know these
answers, we give, we..."
Yeah.
Go work to.
K.
See, this type of score,
see if I can have a class having an
average of 20 to 25 on 30 in EC1.
There's the quizzes and the assignments.
Well,
it makes me feel very happy that I don't
have to give E-grades in the course,
because if you have achieved so much in
assignment and quiz, you definitely,
even if you've used AI,
you've picked up enough knowledge to be
able to write something in the mid-term
exam.
And.
If you write something in the midterm
exam,
your marks are bound to jump up to the
30-40 level.
At least we don't have embarrassing
schools. And it's not as if, you know,
it has happened by,
you haven't slept through it.
You've spent 5 minutes, you've,
and even to be able to understand answers
from AI or be able to put it quickly,
you've at least
In the worst case,
spend 10 minutes browsing through the
slides.
And that is enough to make sure that
you've at least got a fundamental idea.
And of course, those of you who have...
sat through my going through the slides
with you.
Maybe it should give you some major
benefit. OK, so let's see, you have...
Components.
And you have connectors.
You come to know which are the major
components and how they interact with
each other.
Say, this is a client.
Is a server.
There is a communication protocol between
the two.
So,
you will write down what is what are the
connectors?
D.
If you have a client server, the client,
the server.
This might be an IES server,
internet server.
It might be connecting to a database.
So how do you store?
So you might like to draw a diagram to
indicate the type of database,
whether the database is shared by various
systems, or it is,
or your multiple database.
Which part of the systems are replicated,
so you might even show this is a.
set of user interfaces by just indicating
how many they are.
You might even show the flow of data.
How the, what is it you give user ID,
password.
This is.
Accept or reject?
These type of details can also be
indicated.
which part of the system is run in
parallel, if there's computations.
You have a ****.
You might draw a diagram like this,
and then there will be an inter-process
communication.
These are.
asynchronous,
but they have an inter-process
communication.
You might have an inter-process
communication that this process can
terminate that process maybe.
While you are.
Because I mean, PRATEEK.
Printing is going on side by side,
but you can probably send a signal from
here to stop the printing.
Very often we have systems where you
can't stop the printing,
so you don't have inter-process
communication.
So these things could be communicated.
Then,
if the system structure changes while the
system is executing, for example,
you may have a pipe and filter structure.
which goes ABC.
Depending on the condition in A,
it just might have another choice to go
to XC.
So.
You might put a diamond UVM.
Give some value and move this way and
that way.
diamond is depicted like that.
So how you wish to depict?
We allow a lot of flexibility to you.
If you feel that a particular
presentation will help you express
yourself to the customer,
it is going to be acceptable.
There are a lot of standard architectural
diagrams.
We will see some of them in our class
itself.
But those are being shown to you just to
show you that this is how some stalwarts
in the industry have used diagrams.
But you're free to use it as you like.
And
a little bit of familiarity with the
URMILA.
Could help you.
So, if you got no background in...
Drawing diagrams, just though it is a.
URMILA is more for design than for
architecture, but...
German diagrams.
Let me just check up whether there's a
hyphen in between or not.
Yeah, I have, like, India.
dot dot com is dot over G, I think.
It's dot ORG.
It is human dash diagrams.
Yes.
Diagrams.org and it is beautiful to.
These are basically.
Diagrams meant for.
Design, but even as an architect,
it is good if you are aware of this
diagramming.
The UML is Object Management Group is the
custodian OMG.
They are the custodians of human diagrams.
They set the standards and
UML diagram is a standard way of
communication for design. Now,
when you go into design,
I will say that you have to stringently
follow the UML.
specifications. It's a language.
So you can't play around with the
semantics or syntax of a language.
So if you're a designer.
If you aren't already familiar with UML,
it is high time you got yourself familiar
because the power of communication
through UML diagrams is unparalleled.
It's fantastic being able to draw UML
diagrams and let your programmer know
what you expect out of a system.
But as far as an ARCHITA is concerned.
Uh...
Part of your assignment, I think,
requires some sort of a.
presentation which could be done on a
URMILA diagram.
I have to see the assignment to figure
out.
So, in a structure,
what processor does each software limit
execute on? Ohh,
this is the allocation structure, sorry.
This we have finished off.
Then we come to allocation structure.
Allocation structure has got to do with
the assignment of software elements to...
the external environment or to the
hardware.
So external environment could be the
programmers,
could be the company in which the system
is going to function.
It could be to do with the hardware.
So which processors?
What files in each element stored?
The data is stored during development,
testing, system building.
Which development team?
Works on which part of the software?
So,
these type of decisions are recorded in
the allocation structure,
and you have to have views to depict.
So 3 structures,
the three broad types of decisions.
So.
The structures, they influence coding,
they influence runtime behavior,
they influence where the software will
run.
Yeah.
Module, component connector, allocation,
some diagrams are given here.
You can look at the diagram.
These are the various types of module
structures we mentioned it earlier.
You must be aware of each of these types.
And for each of these types.
diagrams are available.
So in module decomposition,
this is something I will answer details
against queries.
If there are any of these,
we'll give a break after a while.
You can go through these components.
And if you want any clarifications,
just pull be back after the break and I
will be happy to explain it to you.
Decomposition uses layered.
class or generalization.
Then we come to component connector via
process or communication process,
concurrency,
shared data or repository and client
server. On allocation,
we've got deployment, implementation,
work assignment. So
The software structure.
This is the relationship and what purpose
it is used. This is continued into.
Three pages.
Here's a small case study given.
And we will, after the break,
we'll start with Gretchen's 4 views.
Crutchins also,
this person is an IBM old timer.
part of the rational group.
Some of you may be connected with
rational because you may be using
rational rules.
Very popular software among designers.
But, uh...
Gretchen has been a part of this group in
IBM,
and we will look at Gretchen's 4 views
after the break. In the meantime,
during the break, I want you to...
pick up any of the items in the first
three structures that you would like me
to discuss soon. Let's go for a break.
It's and the break is 10 minutes.
In future HML.
Kumar Ka Diga.
Okay.
Gonna go over a little thing.
I will.
Play the song.
The bye to.
Open.
U.K.
I need a third, Elijah.
No.
Can you play?
Yeah.
Play N.
Sorry, in Vadena.
I do.
Hmm.
Oh, my.
Play Madepur.
I will understand.
Yep, welcome. Put down any queries.
There have been no queries.
How do?
I take it that those points have been
understood.
Oh.
Okay, yeah,
there were some people who are muted,
have muted them.
Okay, ABASS, if that is...
Full of adware. Yes,
I've also seen just now it has got adware
in it.
Earlier it didn't have so much adware.
Yeah, I suppose.
Tell me.
JABBAL.
Is there any way to block that way?
You see this side?
I've been using it and so far I'm not
impacted,
but then that is no reason why you should
trust the site.
And this is a site which is...
Who's the sponsor of the site?
There doesn't seem to be any sponsor.
UML diagrams dot ORG.
Mm.
It's a privately developed site.
Okay, well.
Yeah.
Okay, Neeraj, let me see whether...
They have given it in Taxila or not, OK?
I should have given it in Takshil,
I have not checked up.
Okay.
E.
Neeraj,
I'm just going to share a page with you,
just see whether it serves your
requirement or not.
Does the SAURAV requirement?
And please unmute and ask if there's
anything more than that that you want to
know.
Is there any additional information,
SARLA?
This is the course handout I've
downloaded from Taxila just now.
Okay, Neeraj wanted it, right?
So, Neeraj, it's in the core center,
just download it, OK?
And marks weightages are given,
assignment MCQ is given there.
So if we can understand the structure of
the subject, you go through that thing,
you get the complete structure of the
subject.
OK, good, good.
Yes, sure, it's maintained privately and..
.
He probably put in ads and you know,
I saw it today and I saw that he's
managed to get a lot of ads. Earlier,
there weren't so many ads. In fact,
he probably started without any ads.
So I've been using this for many years
and I've been recommending it for
students because
You can do without a textbook if you are
watching this site. So maybe you...
Take care of the ad block blocking and
make sure you don't click on any of the
ads. Somebody wanting to learn URMILA,
this is a very convenient site.
So, we let's get back to...
A slide show.
What?
TOM.
Cut just for you,
he says that it's 4 + 1 actually,
one should be a logical view.
The abstraction which are manifested in
the object-oriented world as objects or
object classes.
So logical view, it's a module view,
just indicate which are the key
abstractions.
Then you have a process view.
It addresses concurrencies,
is a component connector view.
What are the processes that will run,
whether they run together or not?
There's a development.
It will take the software modules,
libraries, subsystems.
This, as a result,
constitutes a allocation view,
which are the teams units of development.
In the physical view.
So here we have what are the processing
nodes, communication nodes.
Also a type of a allocation view.
Very often people want to get an idea,
the layman,
as to which are the units that you've got
physically as a part of their thing.
And plus one is normally the scenario,
the use case.
BJ use case is presented so that people
have an idea of what the system does.
We talked about the structures
corresponding to the structures,
we have the view.
And views are the ones which are written
by and read by stakeholders or written by
written for the stakeholders.
Some stakeholders are capable of
sketching them.
And that's why I said that I'm not very
particular about the syntax.
I'm more particular about.
I wish one could live in a house and get
it paid for through advertisements.
You've got to be a celebrity to be able
to do that, of course. Okay.
You take up relevant views.
Obviously, if you can so many structures,
you can have so many views also.
And as an architect,
you go to choose a couple of views.
which will satisfy diverse needs of
different type of stakeholders.
You have completely different type of
stakeholders.
You may have people who are paying for
the system,
the people who are actually going to use
it,
the people who are going to develop the
system,
the people who are going to maintain it,
the people who are going to manage the
environment in which it is going to run
or manage the development of the
Write it myself.
So.
What you do is you pick up a couple of
views.
And you present each of these views with
a particular set of, or a subset of,
stakeholders in mind.
Going back to our earlier example,
we talked about the human body.
The cardiological view,
the orthopedic view,
the endocrinologist view,
the neurologist view, so each person.
The structure is the same.
You have the human body with all the
limbs,
but each specialist wants to see it
differently.
So this is it, the end user.
Will be interested in the logical view,
which is basically the structural, the...
Module structure.
The development view.
And the physical view,
these two would be basically allocation
structures.
The development field would be of
interest to the programmers,
software engineers.
physical view, the system engineers,
people who will work on the topology,
the communication, the hardware,
they would be interested in the physical
view.
The other part to the physical view would
be the component connectors,
that is the process view.
This is basically the module.
This component and connectors.
This is allocation,
and this is also allocation.
So, people are interested in integration,
performance engineering.
Interesting scalability,
they would like to understand the process,
how the load is shared.
Which items can run with concurrency,
which can't? So, for example,
you can have...
Multiple database.
For Reed.
But you'll probably need one database for
right.
Now,
if you can segregate the rights into
different categories,
you can have different database for
rights also.
For heat,
you can replicate and you can have a load
balancer.
which can distribute the read requests
from the write, sinking into read,
may be a separate process.
These sort of things will need to be
depicted.
K.
Kaushik is this way: you draw,
you draw the scenarios,
that's a part of the job you've already
done.
in your assignment.
You?
Break your head with the stakeholders,
you draw the utility tree.
And in the utility tree,
you present your scenarios.
Based on the scenarios,
you develop an architecture. And now,
when you're presenting the architecture,
you don't have to deliver the scenarios.
That can be a documentation on how you
arrived at the architecture.
So these scenarios here will not have the
scenario which we have discussed earlier.
That's when we are talking about this
scenario.
It is not.
Not.
Source stimulus artifact response measure
in an environment.
It is not this.
This scenario is a user story.
So, we'll talk about this in a way.
So, logical view.
object model of the design.
is basically for the end user functional
requirements.
You can use rational rules.
I mentioned a little while back,
rational rules has been a very popular.
Full form.
presenting software design,
you can use the Bush notation,
the Bush notation.
Is.
I think Brady Boucher or something his
name is, so he developed the rotation,
so let's take an example.
This, you just draw a table like this,
indicating that this is how I'm going to
show my class.
plus utility will be like this.
A parameterized class will have a box
like this,
where the parameters will be indicated.
Class category.
Will be like this.
This association, this is a.
Containment aggregator, this is a usage,
usage, inheritance, and instantiation.
So,
instantiation means creating an object of
a class,
inheritance means making a subclass of a
class, usage is...
An object relationship or an object uses
another relation.
Containment or aggregation is basically
one.
Ohh.
One object completely enclosing or
containing a set of objects of a
different type associations 2 objects
interacting with one another.
Rachan has taken the example of PABX.
The ABASS is the old-fashioned telephone
exchange,
but even the newer telephone exchanges
which have come up.
They are modeled around the classic
telephone exchange.
Oh yeah, you know,
PAB exchange used to be used.
When I started my career.
We used to have a telephone operator in
every office,
and the telephone operator had a board
with, say, there were,
your company had five outside lines.
It had five wires here. And here,
it had an extension for each one of us.
So there were 100 people working in the
company. There'll be 100.
Points here.
He will, firstly, he'll receive the call,
then he'll say, okay,
you want to connect to so-and-so.
He'll switch on your switch, talk to you,
then there's a call for you, you say,
okay, connect.
Then he'll physically plug a wire between
these two.
This is how the exchange used to work.
And even earlier, during our childhood,
even the local exchange in the telephone
exchange used to have something like this.
We used to actually have a ringer with a
handle, ring up the exchange.
Somebody picks it up. I said,
please connect me to two six.
And the person would physically connect
me to two six and could listen on to our
calls.
Now, gradually,
this private access board exchanges,
they came up where things were automated,
so...
Once it was automated,
you started having the unit selectors
where...
You are a hunter,
which would hunt for a spare circuit for
you. So when you picked up the phone,
first you hear a hunting tone, tuck, tuck,
tuck.
The very senior people among you just
might have encountered it. Unlikely,
unlikely.
It belongs to a different generation.
And then once it finds a
spare circuit, you get a ringtone, ring,
ring, ring, and then you start dialing.
When you dial,
there's an electromechanical device
called the uniselector,
which would go and gear up and complete a
circuit. And after completing,
you'll find out whether the line at the
other end is free or not.
If the line is free, it will connect. Now,
typically a small exchange will have up
to 10 connections possible.
A bigger exchange could have about 100.
If there were 1000 telephone numbers,
there would be about 100 circuits could
be completed.
Which means, at any point of time,
not everybody can be speaking, so...
If you're speaking to people within the
exchange, 200 people can speak.
If you're speaking to outsiders,
then it depends on the number of outside
lines that particular exchange has got.
So some circuits will be established
outside. So this is a conversation,
the connection that is established in the
conversation.
The terminal in the exchange,
there's a replica of your telephone
instrument, which is called a terminal.
There's a controller which basically
engages these together now.
The terminal has got a numbering plan,
so there's a conversion from the circuits
to the telephone numbers that have been
allotted to you.
The conversation has got a connection
service, so depending on who you are,
the connection is established.
And then translation service is where
your...
Communication is linked to the outside
line,
so your waveform has to be converted to a
form so that it can be carried on a
carrier on AM,
FM band or whatever on a telephone line.
In some form,
it has to be carried over a long distance,
because the way it was in your local
office,
it cannot carry over a long distance, so..
.
Even today,
when these exchanges went electronics,
you represented these,
and today if you write an object-oriented
program,
to simulate an exchange and run it on a
computer. Today,
exchanges run on as a software on a
computer,
and the computer has got special cards
which can connect to outside lines. Now,
these very same objects are created today,
and these are the services
Which will be existing,
and this is how you do the market it as a
module structure.
Then we come to process for you.
Concurrency and synchronization.
There are two types of communication
between components,
asynchronous and synchronous.
Synchronous is,
I say hi until you return my hello,
I'm stuck. I'll keep waiting for you.
When I get into a conversation with any
of you.
Then we are in the synchronous mode.
I say something,
I'll just keep sitting and waiting for
your reply. When you reply,
then I will reply. Asynchronous is...
Some of you are making coffee,
some of you are watching a film on the
side.
Some of you may just have gone off to
sleep in the process of watching the
class, and I carry on on my own.
So this is synchronous.
So our class runs synchronously. Luckily,
because somebody went to sleep,
my class doesn't stop.
Of course, it stops if I go off to sleep.
OK, so.
Anybody who is going to put the system
together would be interested in.
Somebody has decided to bomb the class.
Yes, even.
This type of bombing, it's a nice change,
you know, suddenly from a mundane class,
you have a little bit of noise,
somebody's...
Probably driving a bike, riding a bike,
so I told you that.
We are working asynchronously.
Chucky.
You know,
during these dramas and all that, no,
you used to have these wardrobe
malfunctions.
Suddenly something goes wrong with the
wardrobe and it comes apart.
So this is like a mic malfunction and
sometimes it can be
Very embarrassing.
And I've switched on the camera also some,
so I would caution my fellow friends here,
don't accidentally switch on your camera
the way you do that to your mic,
because that can be more embarrassing
than the mic.
I've had situations like this, like.
With the camera on,
you get to get some very embarrassing
moments if somebody is not careful.
That way,
sometimes this team can be more dangerous
than your site with a lot of ads.
It can expose you totally.
Okay, so here we go.
So.
In a process.
Manifestation,
which is basically component and
character view to understand scalability,
concurrency, performance, and...
This type of rotation has been used by
Christian.
Garland and Shaw, and he has anything.
Multiple levels of abstraction can be
shown here.
There you are.
So...
This whole process has been shown.
This is a simple process.
This is a periodic process,
what being done periodically.
Unspecified connector. This is a message.
This is a remote procedure call.
Remote procedure call is normally.
Could be synchronous,
could be asynchronous message,
bidirectional message,
and event broadcast. So this is the...
Representation put up by Shaw.
Balance show.
And with this rotation, here you are,
the same exchange.
Terminal Software.
Main controller.
Controller DAS.
Low rate tasks, high rate tasks.
So this is a controller process divided
into various sub-processes.
This is the type of communication that is
going on between them.
So just draw a sketch like that,
draw a few boxes, put it across.
Then we have the development view.
and development view something which you
design.
Based on which a lot of decisions can be
taken by the project manager on how to go
ahead with the project.
You may create layers, you may create,
you may decide to use certain tools,
you may decide to use certain programming
languages for various modules, and...
Here we use the booch nutrition and take
the one style is the layered style.
So, here you are, component.
The module is a subsystem.
This is a is just two lines in the Bush
notation is 2 lines in many of our
notations we draw boxes on top of each
other.
But in the Bush tradition,
this will be just shown like this.
And.
Connection between modules will be simply
drawn by.
A line like this.
Here, take, for example, this one.
There's a huge air traffic control system.
Part of it is domain-specific.
Part of it is domain independent.
So you decide to create layers.
So the bottom 2 layers are domain
independent,
so irrespective of which domain uses air
traffic control system is being used.
These 2 layers will be the same.
So basic elements and the distributed
virtual machines.
Binding low-level services,
these are handled by the low system,
all the ATC. ATC is air traffic control,
by the way.
And our author of our textbook has done a
lot of work with the ebcf.
And Huges, those of you who are not aware,
anybody out here working for Huges?
They've been into satellites in a very
big way, satellite communication,
and they've done a lot of work with air
traffic controls also.
This is a company where...
Again.
So, what I have implementation,
I have done implementation for NERS,
Yeah.
so NERS is a basically manufacturing of
air traffic controller, so...
Okay.
Oh, fantastic. Who was speaking?
I couldn't catch the name very quickly.
Whose voice did I hear?
Hello!
But I believe it was someone named.
Was that BHANU, BHANU?
Was that BHANU?
The person who spoke about ATC.
Yeah, I can't hear BHANU. Hello.
BHANU, can we hear you again?
Just say hello.
Hello?
Can you tell?
He seems to be unmuted,
but I don't think he's audible.
Yeah, he is unmuted.
Asynchronous, so,
but he shared some good experience with
us.
And then...
OK, he's driving OK.
No, no, I'm not driving. Hello.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, tell me.
Yeah, I have done implementation,
so there are...
What?
Yeah, yeah, could you hear me now, sir?
We can hear you,
but you seem to be in on some sort of a
No, hi.
AM video. Are you speaking on a call this?
Maybe there are disturbances in the air
traffic controllers.
I tell you, God help you,
I hope you're not using this for actually
controlling the buses. Okay, okay.
Can you just throw some light on this
Yeah.
diagram then?
in the context of what you're doing,
where you fit in in this diagram.
Just tell us where you fit in the diagram.
It will be very interesting to note where
you fit in the diagram in this diagram.
So, in the in the functional area diagram,
so basically we map that attributes and
Let me, yeah.
how we do a maintenance for the ATC,
so that that part we have to put,
Okay.
so we have I have done implementation and
implementation for them next.
Okay,
so do we say that you will be involved in
these two layers?
Yeah, uh, the right one, then the first,
yeah, first top of what?
Huh?
Yeah, we will talk to.
Yes, yes, yes.
And they will be domain specific.
So which companies software are they
using, the one where you maintain?
Yeah, so they are using SAP,
so they we have done a green field
implementation from end to end scenario,
so we are there are different processes
Okay.
they are using and different.
Okay.
Okay, super. So here,
what we've got to understand as a group
is that these two are basic hardware
specific layers.
communication, physical hardware.
And as we move up,
we have the ADC framework.
So there must be some sort of a framework
which handles the aeronautic classes and
ADC classes. On top of this,
you'll be taking care of the ADC
functionalities, flight manager,
sector management there.
whether SAP has done an implementation or
not. Has SAP implemented in these areas,
flight management, sector management?
And then we come to the actual band
machine interface,
which is the user interface,
what type of tools they use. So the CATS,
MATS, they would be HATS.
These are tools which are more specific
to a particular ATC.
And that's why we said that BHANU would
have maintained
Yes, yeah, yeah, so function,
functionality, yeah,
These layers.
I give I give you all the light on that.
So,
Yeah.
in every every every country has their
own guidelines. For example,
Right.
US has a NATO. Similarly,
France has their own compliances,
Right.
Okay.
so there are two compliances: one is the..
.
Body,
and another is a OEM guidelines that need
to be a compliance,
so that we take care in the while doing
Okay.
implementations, yeah.
Superb. So very interesting.
One feels so happy when one finds this is
sitting in the class who has been deep
into these layers.
Recently,
we have implemented for Singapore
Airlines, even though...
Oh,
I hope that information is not
confidential. You are going on record.
Yeah, they can't be confidential.
There'll be enough people who are knowing.
Yeah.
Yeah, so,
so next time I fly to the Singapore
airport airline, I'll think of you.
Excellent airline, superb,
Sure.
So, for airline, yeah, that.
very good service. Yeah,
I've traveled when I when I went to this
So there are two top airlines,
one is Lufthansa, the other Singapore.
thing, yeah, yeah.
The both I have done implementation for
both.
Okay, you're calling favorites.
Next time you do work for Emirates,
you'll say Emirates is the best.
So anyway, so that's all right. Yeah,
I've traveled Etihad, Emirates, excellent.
And even.
The customization,
I've traveled Lufthansa also and I've
traveled Singapore. Yeah,
I've tried all these.
So actually time to time also things vary
and then it's your individual experience
in a given flight that makes a difference.
So
Sometimes you are lucky with the,
actually ultimately is the man part of
the man machine,
which makes a big difference.
If you have a nice crew on a particular
flight, the flight is good for you.
So, that factor is there,
but then the airlines you work for are
known as top-rated airlines. So,
so that way we've got a glimpse of the
development view and dwell into layers
and see this helps in allocation because
of the...
classes,
BHANU could decide to work on these two.
And within this company,
there'll be different teams working for
each of these.
And then they will fully divide it out
into sectors.
And so before any work could be done,
this is an allocation view where the work
is divided into parts.
And then you have the physical view.
Again.
Getting into the physical view will
probably get too detailed.
I'm sure BHANU can tell you about where
he would have installed,
but then today's class we'll have nothing
else.
So these non-functional requirements,
reliability, availability, performance,
they'll all be addressed.
Test and development development,
and here it is a typical.
Patient use for physical infrastructure,
the processes, the processors,
other devices,
the communication between them.
Non-permanent communication is a dotted
line.
Unidirectional communication is with an
arrow. High bandwidth communication,
you draw a thick line.
And we go back to a PABX example.
We have the primary exchanges,
which we have a backup.
This may interact with primary at the
next level, which will also have a backup,
and these can have the leaf nodes.
Which interact with the primaries?
So, you have a conversation process?
It interacts with the terminal.
and the terminal interacts with the
controller.
So this could be a typical physical view
of the way a conversation is being
handled.
And.
Based on that,
you can combine the previous two diagrams.
You have a control process which handles
the central process, the communication,
and the terminal,
and then you have the subprocess which
have the controllers and the line cards.
Line cards are the cards, you know,
I mention this to you because I have
worked on it years back.
But why it's important to use that all
over the place in IT,
we have physical representation and
logical representations.
A simple example is C drive, D drive.
X drive, Y drive, Z drive.
No,
basically you'll mount some sort of
stories and you'll call it X.
You'll bound something, call it VYOM,
mount something,
you can create a virtual drive somewhere
and call it C.
The overall hardware could be a single
hardware and will be divided into C&D.
Similarly, in the telephone exchange,
you've got logical circuits and you've
got physical circuits.
The physical circuits is the last mile,
the wire that travels from the telephone
exchange to your house.
Or if you've got a sub-exchange within
your house or your office,
from the sub-exchange to your phone.
But...
Within the microprocessor or the software
that handles the...
working,
it's got its own numbering system,
its own identity of each circuit,
which has been mapped when a circuit was
allotted to you. In the line card,
you actually connect your logical
circuits with your physical circuits.
This is what the line cards are about.
So this type of a diagram. Now
Putting all fields together,
use all users and evaluators,
consider system consistency and validity
notation similar to logical view.
So, you present a scenario.
This person.
So this is called in this very similar to
the UML notation called communication
diagram.
Only in a communication diagram,
you simply have boxes.
You don't have this type of notation.
But Philip Kutchner decided to use these
notations for individual classes and the
conversation that is handled between them
shown by arrow.
The communication diagram has it exactly
like this, one, two, three.
That means one is off hook.
Response is dial tool, you enter digits.
These digits go to a numbering plan and
then...
When you have dialed your full number,
you get into a conversation.
This communication diagram.
can also be signified by a sequence
diagram.
And the raw text form of the sequence
diagram is called the use case diagram.
So.
This is when it comes to design, but this.
is more modular, the modules,
it is not at a detailed level,
but we call this a scenario because it
gives the interaction that takes place.
Then we come to the correspondence
between views.
These views are interconnected.
Remember one thing,
the system is the same.
There are only different ways of seeing
the system.
Now, let's take a look at it.
You can see inside out,
start from the logical, and outside in,
start from the physical, so...
As I told you in anything with computing.
You start with logic.
And I then say something physical.
So, from logical to process view,
you can connect the logical views there
and the process views there.
You can connect the two to each other.
Then from logical view,
we can proceed to developing field.
So you can connect all the parts in the
logical view to the development view.
Teams in the organization,
the class categories which include the
packages.
Classes can be grouped into packages.
You can talk about the lines of code,
how many lines of code are required for
each module.
Then this entire process of documenting
an architecture can be viewed as an
iterative process. Now,
this iteration is slightly different from
the...
iterations we talk about in agile
development or in the unified process
model.
Here what happens is we take the most
significant
Components first.
Decide what architectural decisions need
to be taken early in the life cycle.
Take those decisions,
keep all of the decisions as pending.
We don't freeze everything that needs to
be frozen, doesn't need to be frozen.
I was hoping to get a little bit of time
to do some review on quality attributes.
Let me see.
So.
This is how we are treat.
And when we present the full
documentation,
this could be a typical layout.
We are not going to ask you to do this as
a part of any of your assignments.
You don't need to do it in so much of
detail. We have given you a template,
which has asked for a very limited
presentation.
So you don't have to follow this
The nomenclature for your assignment.
ATC Telecom,
so it has been successfully used by IBM.
So...
Some inconsistency have been pointed out.
So, here you go to somebody.
We got various views.
These are the views as for a crutcher.
And these are the.
Views that we.
Is that everything the views we have seen
here?
In.
When you have a view.
These are the five views we talk about.
So each of them have got component
connectors, containers, stakeholders,
concerns, and tool support.
So which one we use where?
has been indicated in this matrix.
Let's take a typical example: tool
support.
You could use rational rules for logical
structure.
These are tools which can be used for
showing the process view,
development view,
you could use these tools.
There are various tools that can be maybe
used.
You won't actually be getting engaged
with them.
You sketch it whichever way you like.
We'll have no problem.
Conference.
Logical class.
and process is a task,
and developing is a modular subsystem.
Physically, it's a node.
Scenario is a step.
So these are the parts of any of these
views.
So, this way, you can...
understand what the 4 plus 1 module
covers.
So.
SAI is the Software Engineering Institute.
Software Engineering Institute.
They have their own categories, modules,
components, characters, allocation,
and we have mapped it.
We have discussed this while we are doing
it also, logical process development.
So,
primary focus in module or logical view
is a functional decomposition, classes,
layers, etc.
Component character is a process view,
runtime behavior.
throughput, scalability, et cetera.
These are both allocation views,
development view and physical view.
In the development view,
we talk about mapping software to file
systems, work environment,
the actual coders.
Physical view is mapping software and
hardware or cloud.
So,
this is how the Software Engineering
Institute and the and questions focus on
view, they match each other.
When you talk about modernizing the
logical view.
You can use URMILA 2.5.
So modern architects,
they tend to use your values.
As far as we are concerned,
you can do any sketching that you require
for this course.
You can drop class diagrams,
packages diagrams also,
if you're getting into a little bit of
detail.
In.
in the microservices world.
When you talk about logical view,
you'll be talking about service API
contracts, domain boundaries,
bounded contexts.
So this is the change in the language in
today's world.
So you've got to understand that in the
last one or two years,
Whatever work you've done,
you will not see the similarity of what
we study in theory, but...
Irrespective of how modern modern music
is and what is the form of modern music.
It's always a good idea to learn your
basic basics,
starting with your Doremi or your
Sarikamappa.
Then you learn your RAJ and then you get
into modern usages. So when we teach,
we take up ancient concepts,
what have built up
to what it is today. And today,
definitely, in today's environment,
you've got to be aware of domain
boundaries,
you've got to be aware of APIs.
So when you make a logical view,
you will be actually presenting your APIs
rather than...
Many of the components you will not even
construct.
You will be taking make and buy decision.
And buy has become used up.
So, make or use?
Earlier,
make and buy used to have a very
complicated rule. If you make,
it's going to cost you.
Yeah.
Hundred 1000.
If you buy, it's going to cost you 75.
Okay, so you went in for bye.
No,
you have a concept called use is going to
cost you 1K per annum.
Now, would you?
If you,
what should you make and what should you
use?
issues of security, issues of...
modifiability.
So these sort of decisions start getting
involved because nowadays most software
that you use, you only pay for use.
And it's not only for the overall
software, individual components.
Do I make a component or use a third
party API?
Then the repetition of the API,
maintenance,
whether what is the guarantee of
maintenance,
whether they will continue to support or
not.
How robust is that API?
And how robust is the team?
Is the team like you to survive?
I go in for something which is very fancy,
but after five years is not available,
my investment is lost.
Then, evolution of process view.
Used to talk about concurrency,
load balancers,
adding additional servers in the cloud
data stories become.
far more relevant or even stronger.
Instead of having virtual machines,
you've got dockers, you've got containers.
Instead of writing out modules,
you're using service list functions,
things like Lambda. You want to...
Know your location on a map?
Just you just pay for the mapping service,
This.
and...
So...
When we come to dynamic behavior,
we used to have sequence diagrams
essential for showing components exchange
message over time.
We have activity diagrams to module the.
to show the business workflow.
And activity diagrams,
most of us draw activity diagrams as
swimming diagrams.
Again, beyond the preview of this course,
but I would like you to be aware that
these things exist.
In the examination paper,
you are not going to be asked to draw an
activity diagram or a sequence diagram or
a swim net diagram,
but you have to be aware that these are
the type of diagrams that are used for
depicting.
Sequence diagrams. I told you earlier,
when I was talking about sequence diagram,
I talked about communication diagram.
Communication diagram and sequence
diagram, they represent the same activity,
but a different form of presentation.
Those of you who have been involved in
design would understand what I'm saying.
If you don't understand, forget it.
But remember that there are things called
communication diagrams, sequence diagrams.
And concern is...
You talk about latency deadlocks.
Concept of eventual consistency,
which we will touch on later on when we
go into distributed Architectures and
cloud computing, so...
Then we talk about the cap theorem.
And those of you who have been working on
cloud-based systems with international
distribution of functionality,
you'll be very well aware of what the CAP
theorem is,
but we'll take it up much later in the
course.
What about development view?
The build environment.
DevOps, continuous integration,
continued deployment, delivery.
These have become.
A matter of state, so then we come to...
Development view,
we've got to see it in the context,
DevOps, and even DevOps,
the language seems to be becoming.
Oh, thank you very much. This is over.
You can read the last few pages on your
own.
Got carried away.
The stuff was interesting.
Thanks a lot for warning me.
I normally don't overstay.
OK, Abash, thanks a lot. So long.
Look forward to seeing you next week
again. Bye bye.
Thank you, Jeff.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye.
Thank you, sir. Bye.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you, so bye.
Thank you. Bye, bye, bye.